what's this fun you know like like the
birth like offspring you know like your
spawn is your thing you gave birth to
its you're passing your genes along so
spawns a sperm kind of yeah well it's
like a sperm is it's really the sperm
mixed with the egg I'm Greg now I'm John
I'm Andrew there was one time the three
of us decided to actually hang out here
and just have a night to ourselves and
we play Mortal Kombat together and I
whup that asses I made jaws like a bunch
of panthous yeah we looked like idiots
so I thought let's watch the trailer for
spawn here
[Music]
together we can purge the 10 mils
oh maybe follow my feet that's not oh
man is circle teats fire Michael Jai
White's voice yeah it sounds just like
Michael day well yeah I am gonna kick
him up late this is her spark business
partner okay yeah
Wow it is great Dean spot here brandy
wasn't mercenary for a house
Al Simmons rules can't wait to see his
fate ality oh oh damn
yeah
[Music]
oh my Wow Wow I just want to know
where's John who's almost violated right
see them yeah yeah I mean that's what
we've really been waiting for combat is
fun Jack yeah I'm excited for the
upcoming spawn movie but in the meantime
this is great they really brought spawn
to life here the chains the guns what
he's invisible I'm kind of curious about
that because I'm like how do you
possibly beat him when he's cloaking
himself and as the player how do you
know what you're doing that was the kind
of thing we're like if you get hit you
come out of it or something
one thing with Mortal Kombat's like you
kind of get used to the amount of
brutalities and combos and whatnot with
the characters and the best way for them
to mix it up is really honoring whatever
new DLC characters they have and they
have brought the comics character spawn
to life here this looks great can't wait
to use him to beat both your lasses to
make you look like a bunch of Panthers
ah well you know what I really wish the
finishing move would have been is just
todd mcfarlane coming out and telling
you how great this dlc because like todd
mcfarlane is the biggest fan ever but
yeah this is just look so badass to me
especially those fatalities where you
see the demon hands come up and when
score being apart and then he's flayed
and then like just the amount of
imagination I feel like that's the main
thing we always come back to it the
imagination for beautifully horrifying
Gore's off-the-chain in these things ha
Shane yeah Todd McFarlane's boner was
huge when he saw this cuz I know mine
was but ya know todd mcfarlane yeah Todd
McFarlane must be really happy watching
this cuz this looks really sick yes
there we greg keeps he was
this looks it's it's coming really happy
watching this is this look like you guys
said this is the complex but back - I
love the shot of my Bhoja at the end I
mean yeah but ya know that was really
sick to see and I let other also showing
the mercenary sideways shooting the
machine gun and like do them then you
get that like one shot of the guy's
eyeball being shot at like pretty
graphic I like yeah I'm like this spawn
we need a spawn movie that's as graphic
is this spawn versus Joker let's do is
get it on all right guys well who are
you more excited to play ass Joker or
spawn leave your thoughts down below or
t800 oh man you see that one yeah that
was if we just had the Roses it's like
it goes in roses three-way battle man
and there it goes Andrew again it will
subscribe notification bell follow
Andrew somewhere see you guys